Courtney is with us Courtney's in Miami
hi Courtney welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave thanks for taking my call
how are you better than I deserve what's
up okay so I have a sort and sweet
question for you so I'm actually really
excited to be talking to your house I
just pulled in the bank and I'm about to
walk in and make my last payment of $500
towards my one and only credit card and
then I'm completely debt free why did it
go yes
so I'm really excited so my question is
what do I do with this credit card do I
shove it in a drawer or do I cut it up
or do I close it close the account okay
yeah that way there's no nothing
fraudulent can happen on it it's just
gone okay okay and you don't
accidentally use it then either right
okay so that's not going because I've
had a couple credit cards in the past
and people said don't close it because
it's going to affect your credit score
and it'll lower your credit score but
that doesn't matter
get rid of it close the account you're
done with that if you're not if you're
gonna play footsie with this stuff
you're never going to stay out no no I
know and I don't want you so the credit
score doesn't matter correct if I have
if I pay cash for everything right
exactly if you're not borrowing money
nobody needs your credit score okay that
so yeah yes that's easy enough
I'm so excited thank you so much and
thank you for taking me on this journey
it's an I've paid off so much debt and
it feels good to be five minutes away
from being debt-free I'm proud of you
how old are you
I'm thirty why did it go you're single
thank you yeah I'm saying first time
you've ever been debt-free as an adult
yes Wow how's your you and I you're
getting ready to walk in here and cut
the last thread yeah I love this moment
this is a great moment and you're not
doing it online you're walking into the
frickin branch and putting it in their
face yeah I'm sitting in front of the
bank right now and I cannot I'm like I'm
ready to cry because this is I mean I
don't have any college college loans I
know how as long as my car is paid off I
don't have a I don't have a mortgage I
am
so lucky to live with my dad and so yeah
I don't have after this it's all up from
here and I don't have anymore dad what's
the name of the bank
it's a wildfire credit union okay hey
make sure you take like a picture of the
outside right before you walk in okay
yeah and so you can keep it keep this
memory you want to store this because
you're gonna tell your grandkids this
someday yeah 20 I went to wildfire and
paid it off right I know well and I
don't and I don't ever want my kids and
I wish that as a I wish that as a kid in
the team that I would have known what I
know now and I wish that I was taught
this in school and I wasn't so this is
super great for me to like pass on to my
kids and my grandkids just to show them
you know this is not the way that you
want to do things I love it you're a
rock star kiddo
so proud of you go pay it off touchdown
whoa